في الخارج،
نحصل الآن على صورة أوضح عن
مدى الأضرار التي لحقت بالزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا، حيث تقدر تقديرات البنك الدولي
أكثر من 34 مليار دولار
من الأضرار المادية المباشرة في تركيا
وحدها، أي ما يعادل حوالي أربعة
بالمائة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي لتركيا في عام 2021، في حين أن
البنك الدولي  يقول إن
إعادة البناء ستكلف ضعف التكلفة الآن، وينضم إلينا البشير على الهواء مباشرة
من إسطنبول، ولا يتعلق الأمر بالتكلفة فحسب، بل
بالتحدي
الذي تواجهه تركيا في إعادة البناء في مثل هذه
المنطقة الواسعة، وهو مدى
يصعب تخيله حقًا، أليس كذلك؟  "لقد كنت على
الأرض الآن لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع
فقط أصف مدى صعوبة هذا الأمر،
أعني أن التحدي هو التقليل من
حجم الدمار الهائل على أقل
تقدير في الحكومة التركية التي
تواجه الآن ضغوطًا متزايدة بشأن
العثور على تلك الحلول طويلة المدى، نحن
نتحدث عن مئات ومئات
الآلاف من الأشخاص الذين
نزحوا بسبب هذا الزلزال، وتجارة ضخمة
من الأراضي التي سويت بالأرض بالكامل
في جميع أنحاء جنوب شرق تركيا، وبالنسبة
لتلك المباني التي لم
تنهار، فهي ببساطة  غير آمنة للغاية
للعودة إليها وهذا هو السؤال الرئيسي
الآن، سلامة هذه المباني. هناك الكثير
من التقارير حول العفو عن المباني
الآمنة والتي تم تقديمها لأولئك
الذين لا تستوفي المباني
معايير السلامة سواء كان ينبغي محاسبة الحكومة التركية أم لا.
وهذه الإجراءات هي
مصدر القلق حيث بدأت الحكومة الآن في
الإشراف على عملية إعادة البناء، وقد
تعهد الرئيس أردوغان بالفعل بإعادة
بناء المناطق المتضررة في غضون
عام واحد على الرغم من أن الكثيرين يقولون إن الأمر قد
يستغرق وقتًا أطول بكثير من ذلك، وقد
بدأنا بالفعل نرى ذلك  تم بالفعل تنفيذ الأعمال
الجارية في أجزاء من أعمال التنقيب في غازيانت
لبناء
أكثر من 800100
مبنى سكني لأولئك الذين
نزحوا بسبب الزلزال،
وتقول الحكومة إنها تخطط للبدء في
بناء
30000 شقة أخرى في مارس، لذلك هناك  هناك
جهود جارية بالفعل لإنشاء هذه
المنازل الدائمة لأولئك الذين
نزحوا، ولكن بالطبع
أثار ذلك أيضًا رد فعل عنيف لأننا نسمع
انتقادات للحكومة تقول الآن
إنه ببساطة متسرع جدًا بالنسبة
للحكومة لبدء التفكير في
إعادة البناء في هذه المناطق  ما زلنا
نرى الجثث يتم انتشالها من تحت
الأنقاض، والدمار هائل للغاية
وهناك مخاوف حقيقية بشأن
سلامة هذه المناطق مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
أنها لا تزال تقع على خطوط الصدع هذه،
وما زلنا نشهد هذه
الهزات الارتدادية القوية والآن  يقول اتحاد
المهندسين والمهندسين المعماريين هنا في تركيا أن
هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من
التحقيقات الجيولوجية للتأكد من أن
هذه المناطق آمنة ولكن بالطبع
تتعرض الحكومة لهذا
الضغط الهائل بسبب حجم
النزوح وقمنا بزيارة بعض
تلك المخيمات وهناك  تنتشر العشرات من
هذه المخيمات الآن حول سكان جنوب شرق
تركيا الذين يعيشون في خيام،
ويتقاسم العديد منهم تلك الخيام مع عدد
كبير من الأشخاص الجدد على مدار ثلاثة أجيال في
بعض الحالات، وهم في
حاجة ماسة إلى حلول طويلة الأمد للمأوى طويل الأمد
لبعض العائلات التي نوفرها.  لا
يزال الأشخاص الذين اجتمعوا ليس لديهم خيام، وما زالوا لا
يملكون مأوى، وبالطبع مع
اقتراب الانتخابات، من
المتوقع أن يزداد الضغط على الحكومة.